[Music]
well brian hopefully got outside to
enjoy just a slightly cooler
temperatures ted i don't know what the
exact degree difference was but it
really felt so much more
comfortable today yeah slightly cooler
than yesterday and of course more
sunshine
definitely way better than last week
right we're 109
in some neighborhoods last week right
now we want to show you the live look
outside a couple clouds overhead right
now as we look towards the
south of the strip on top of the strat
cam 93 degrees are high for the day
today
slightly cooler than where we should be
for this time of the year 70 is what we
bottomed down at overnight how about the
record on this day
that was 112 way back in 2013.
temperatures outside right now at 87
summerlin 94 in centennial hills
93 downtown 94 sunrise manor and same
goes for you in green valley whitney
ranch 89 for rhodes ranch mountains edge
94 for southern highlands and the east
side coming in 96 degrees actually for
uh
for henderson there excuse me 89 for
pump 95 for mesquite 95
also for laughlin 98 death valley right
now radar network
dry conditions we had those storm severe
storms
out in denver and that's all cleared up
and same goes for the desert southwest
all the way down to socal
and over to the bay area big trough here
in the jet stream you can see this big
dip here within this is cooler air
now already seeing some of that cooler
air already in the northwest part of the
state
this trough will slowly move its way in
the access will move overhead as we get
to thursday
and that means temperatures will drop
even more
but we will get some winds ahead of that
from the southwest so prepare for a
breezy evening
and then also gusty winds expected
tomorrow there's your wednesday look at
our neighborhoods here double digit wind
speeds
and then also for thursday two and then
we'll see those numbers start to drop as
we head into friday
and into saturday in fact we'll see
those gusty winds tomorrow and thursday
they could peak out to 35 in some spots
maybe some isolated areas at 40
but then notice those winds die down and
then we'll see the breezy winds return
later on the weekend
and into early next week here's your
forecast 72 overnight we'll look for
increasing clouds
breezy this evening and then windy
tomorrow
95 degrees clouds in the morning and
then we'll see sun
as the day progresses like we said we
will have those gusts up to the 35 in
some spots highs tomorrow neighborhood
by neighborhood 93 centennial hills
stand for mountains edge north las vegas
you'll be at 94 along with aliante
93 for henderson and 97 for green valley
hotter of course death valley will be
104 tomorrow
93 boulder city and 102 for laflin
here's your eight day forecast you're
eight on the eight
numbers start to go up even more on
friday but look at your temperature drop
on thursday down to 90 now
and then we'll see a hot weekend and
extra hot next week
brian back over here all right